[Музика]
Ласкаво просимо назад, давайте поговоримо більше про
роботу, хлопці, кілька уроків ідуть ми читаємо
оголошення про вакансії, ми написали CVS і намагаємося
подати заявку на вакансії на цьому уроці, вам
потрібно буде написати власне оголошення про роботу, щоб ви
буде роботодавцем, і вам
доведеться рекламувати свою роботу та наймати
працівників, тому влаштування на роботу, як
отримати роботу,
прочитайте наведені нижче поради та розташуйте їх у
правильному порядку, тому подивіться, ми маємо
чекати, щоб почути рішення, якщо  ви не
отримуєте роботу, поверніться до першої зупинки,
потім подивіться, які вакансії є, а потім
підіть на співбесіду, якщо ви отримали
роботу, почніть роботу, подайте заявку на роботу та
виберіть роботу, яку ви можете зробити добре, щоб
кроки змішалися  подивіться, у вас є
30 секунд або, можливо, трохи більше,
і підготуйтеся до своїх відповідей
добре, у вас є власне замовлення добре,
давайте перевіримо, щоб першим кроком було побачити,
які вакансії доступні, знайдіть на ринку праці,
а потім виберіть роботу, яку ви можете  зробіть
те, що у вас є кваліфікація, а потім
подайте заявку на t  його робота, ви пам'ятаєте, що ми
написали резюме минулого разу, і ви знаєте, як
це зробити, а потім піти на співбесіду дуже
важлива річ, і ви повинні бути готовим
до співбесіди, а потім чекати, щоб почути
рішення, яке насправді може зайняти навіть
тиждень або  два, щоб прийняти ваше рішення, тоді, якщо
ви отримали роботу, почніть роботу, а якщо ви
не отримали роботу, поверніться до першого
кроку і виконайте це ще раз, добре, тож тепер
давайте подивимося на перші чотири
оголошення про роботу нижче, що таке  завдання ми виконаємо
це в парах, наприклад, одна пара завдань,
а інша запишіть ваші відповіді в кожному
місці, ми маємо вгадати слово, можливо, у
вас будуть інші ідеї, ніж у мене
,
всі відповіді можливі, якщо вони
вам підходять  терміново потрібен перший велосипед,
це означає, що він нам
потрібен саме зараз, у вас повинен бути
велосипед під шоломом, ви повинні добре знати
центр міста, ви повинні знати, як
швидко та безпечно писати, ви повинні бути
фізично ногами, не потрібний досвід,
і ця робота є  в Лондоні
добре фізично здорова с  люди, які знають центр міста,
ми можемо швидко писати, які знають їхні
правила та, на щастя, не мають досвіду,
необхідного
для дітей, підходить
для студентів першого курсу університету,
потім приходить друга ексклюзивна команда, яка
шукає аеробіку, кого ви повинні бути
фізично здоровими, ви повинні знати  як
танцювати та займатися аеробікою,
ви повинні бути доброзичливими та мати гарне
ставлення до роботи вранці та ввечері,
потрібен досвід у Манчестері, тому
робота знаходиться в Манчестері, і знову вони
шукають людей, які мають фізичну форму, і
ви повинні мати певну кваліфікацію,
як-от вміти танцювати  а щоб займатися
аеробікою, ви повинні мати дуже
хороші м'які навички міжособистісного спілкування, ви
повинні бути дружелюбними та мати гарне ставлення,
а що це за професії:
перша та друга, як ви
думаєте, хлопці, подивіться й вирішите, добре
тут  чи є мої відповіді, ваші відповіді можуть
відрізнятися, тому я думаю, що перша
робота для месенджера кур'єра, а
друга для інструктора або  Ви
можете сказати тренер, можливо, якщо ви йдете на щось,
що близьке до цієї роботи, ви
на правильному шляху, добре, ця наступна пара
першокласного нью-йоркського ресторану потребує,
можливо, кухарів,
можливо, офіціантки, давайте почитаємо хорошу оплату та
підказки, хм, не тільки платять, але й клієнти
може дати вам додаткову роботу ввечері та
вихідні у вас повинна бути хороша пам'ять, ви
повинні мати професійну зовнішність без
пірсингу, ви повинні мати
досвід англійської мови, а
робота в Нью-Йорку, ну які обмеження
без пірсингу мм-хм, і ви повинні
добре говорити англійською  і професійний
зовнішній вигляд дуже суворі вимоги
насправді добре давайте подивимося наступну
зірку Голлівуду зірка Голлівуду чи можете ви
повірити, що їй потрібно піклуватися про
шестимісячну дитину добре дуже маленька
дитина відмінна оплата і довгі години хороші
гроші, але довгі години це  означає, що ви
повинні працювати до пізньої ночі, ви повинні
бути дуже терплячими, звичайно, вам
потрібно бути терплячим, щоб працювати з
шестимісячною дитиною, ви повинні мати великий
досвід роботи з молодими чи  ldren багато
досвіду відмінні рекомендації необхідні
рекомендації хтось має розповісти щось
дійсно хороше про вашого попереднього
роботодавця, і робота в Лос-Анджелесі
добре оплачується, але потрібні довгі години та
багато досвіду, то що ви
думаєте про першу роботу, тому я  думаю,
що перша робота - це робота офіціанта чи
офіціантки, звідки я знаю, що це тому, що
вони платять не тільки зарплату, але й дають
чайові, а друга робота -
няня-груша чи няня, дуже цікава
робота, як au pair  студент, який
приїжджає з-за кордону, можливо, до Сполучених
Штатів, до Німеччини чи до Франції в будь-яку
країну насправді, і ця людина живе
в сім’ї та допомагає з дітьми
, їй платять трохи, але найкраща
перевага полягає в тому, що вам потрібно, щоб ви  може
вивчати мову сім'я, яка
приймає вас, оплачує ваші мовні курси,
і ця програма Au-Pair дуже
популярна серед студентів, особливо
в літні періоди, це хороший
шанс заробити гроші
та  тер іноземною мовою,
няня та няня, що ці вакансії
дуже поширені, і ви знаєте переклад
або можете також добре тлумачити ці слова,
тому це приклади того, як
це оголошення має бути написане, давайте
продовжимо, поки пишете власне оголошення про роботу, яке
ви повинні  дайте відповіді на ці
запитання,
подивіться, тож перше запитання, на яке вам
потрібно відповісти, – це яка робота, а
в оголошеннях, які ви прочитали, вони
шукали та назва роботи,
які обов’язки має виконувати особа, яка
претендує на вашу роботу  зрозумійте
свої обов’язки, тоді яка
робота – це робота тривалий час
або це робота, щоб працювати за гнучким графіком
, якщо вам доводиться працювати з 9:00 до 5:00,
тому люди повинні знати, чого ви
очікуєте  скільки часу вони повинні працювати, а потім
приходить, де робота, місце розташування.
Вам потрібно знати, ми повинні знати, де
ми отримуємо цю роботу, в якому місті чи
навіть країні, потім яка погодинна ставка,
скільки ви збираєтеся платити людині
за годину у  Ви бачите, що
ви можете отримати зарплату по-різному, це одна
сума грошей, яку ви отримуєте на місяць, тож вона не
змінюється
, це зарплата, а інша виплачує нашу
заробітну плату, це означає, що вам платять за годину,
і ви повинні вирішити, що  погодинна ставка
потім приходить скільки днів вам потрібно
працювати іноді їм
потрібно лише на вихідних, щоб підтримати
основну команду, наприклад у ресторанах,
коли у вихідні ресторани
зайняті більше, ніж у будні, і їм потрібно
підтримати команду та отримати більше  наприклад, офіціанти чи
більше кухарів, то наступне
запитання, на яке потрібно відповісти у своєму дуже
короткому оголошенні, – якими навичками вам
потрібно володіти, чи потрібен вам кваліфікований працівник,
чи потрібен вам диплом, що
насправді працівник повинен робити
та  наступне, чи потрібна вам якась ліцензія для
цієї роботи, наприклад, якщо ви
рекламуєте роботу водія, які
права повинні мати особа
, звичайно, водійські права і так далі,
добре, тому я зробив для вас зразок написання
і насправді я  Мабуть, мій зразок
відповідає на всі запитання, які ми маємо в
цьому списку зараз, чи не могли б ви приділити
хвилинку й знати запитання, а
потім перевірте, чи я
все зробив правильно, добре
[Музика]
добре, так це  це мій зразок оголошення, тепер
давайте прочитаємо його, тому нам потрібні медичні
реєстратори на неповний робочий день,
потрібні медичні реєстратори в будні з
10:00 до 14:00
Обов’язки включають відповіді на телефонні дзвінки
та призначення зустрічей. Кандидатам потрібно
добре володіти англійською 20,00 дол. США на годину,
посвідчення водія є бажаним, але не
обов’язковим, будь ласка, надішліть своє резюме доктору.  J
tan Forest Hill clinic 3 руб.
Сонечко через t 20 добре, так що я зрозумів
усе добре, про що ми говорили
у запитаннях, давайте повернемося до
запитань, а потім знову до
зразка оголошення, тож повернемося до
питання, яка робота  не
відповів обов'язки тип роботи де
погодинна ставка скільки днів навички та
ліцензія давайте подивимося, так яка робота
медичних реєстраторів робочі години та
дні так ми маємо, що це будні,
тож це означає з понеділка по  П’ятниця
і робочий час зазвичай переходять на
14:00  для робочого часу на день і робота
на неповний робочий день, тоді обов'язки так,
обов'язки ми ви повинні відповідати на телефонні дзвінки
та призначатися на зустрічі, тоді
вимога англійської мови гарна англійська
і ґвалтівник наші 20 доларів на годину це означає,
що ви можете заробити 80 доларів США за годину  день потім
водійські права бажано, але не
обов'язково, і зверніть увагу, що спеціальні
водійські права не просто звичайні,
тоді ми маємо адресу, у нас є
вал dr.  J tan, і у вас є місце,
куди ви повинні надіслати своє резюме, тому
все включено, тому це дуже
короткий текст, але він містить багато
інформації, іноді добре, ви
пишете англійською, вам потрібно написати
коротко, і це називається писати для
bruit  e це означає, що вам не потрібно
писати довгі есе, коли ви пишете
рекламу, ви повинні бути дуже точними та
точними, добре, тому ваші домашні завдання я
скажу це ще раз наприкінці
уроку,
вам доведеться рекламувати  робота, з якою ви можете
працювати з партнером, щоб ви могли взяти свого
однокурсника та працювати разом, виберіть
цікаву роботу та напишіть оголошення про роботу, не
забудьте вказати, що таке робота
, місце розташування, заробітна плата, години досвід та
навички, необхідні всі ті питання, з якими ми
мали справу під час цього уроку
добре, тому якщо вам потрібно повернутися до
уроку, і якщо ви дивитеся нас на
YouTube, просто поверніться, зробіть роздрукований екран
і попрацюйте з цією рекламою зараз, хлопці, оскільки
ми підходимо до кінця навчального
року, нам потрібно зробити  деяка переробка, і
сьогодні ми розпочнемо повороти перегляду
протягом останніх двох місяців, відновіть його разом із вами
різними граматичними темами, і я б хотів, щоб
ви сьогодні переглянули ці часи, які ви бачите
на екрані, тож, будь ласка, ви не заперечуєте
і чи не могли б ви пригадати їх так
перші присутні просто, а
тепер прогресивні. Ви можете побачити, як вони
утворені,
тітка, ви можете побачити ключові слова, такі, що представлені
просто, що це звичайна дія, що відбувається
щодня, і ви можете використовувати завжди часто
зазвичай завжди нервує і так далі,
щоб сказати, що ця пряма дія є
відбувається регулярно, потім теперішнє
прогресивне або його також називають поточним
безперервним, але я хотів використати цей час
прогресивним, щоб нагадати вам, що ми
говоримо про прогрес, і ви можете
побачити формулу, тож це M є R + дієслово +
ing, а приклад:  наче я йду або
він йде, коли знаю, що я стою
, ти слухаєш під ключовими словами, які
ви бачите дивіться слухайте зараз,
добре, так що наступна пара вже минула
просто і минулий прогрес  вони зазвичай
складаються в одному реченні, а для простого минулого
вам потрібна друга форма, а
вирази часу вчора останній, а
точна дата в минулому і минуле
прогресивне знову прогресивне означає, що
дія виконується в якийсь час
у минулому, і це  використовується, щоб знову розповісти або розповісти
про довгу дію, а
ключові слова: поки і коли добре моя
мама танцювала
мій батько співав щасливу
картину сім'ї добре наступна наступна пара
має справу з майбутнім, тому ми будемо
Майбутнє ви пам’ятаєте про передбачення
та рішення на місці, наприклад, я
думаю, що зараз я буду їсти гамбургер,
або я думаю, що завтра піде дощ, або я
думаю, що ви всі будете дуже успішними
людьми, це моє передбачення, тому вам знадобиться
, а потім  перша форма іменника
та ключові слова: завтра, наступне,
а наступне іде в майбутнє, це
означає, що коли ви говорите про свої
рослини, наприклад, я збираюся намалювати
картину
я купив фарби я купив с  ome
пензлі, і я насправді збираюся
щось зробити, і це використовується для розмови
про майбутню дію, яка запланована,
ключові слова майже однакові
завтра і наступний, але значення
різне Я не передбачаю я розповідаю
про план або  Я говорю про щось
дійсно очевидне, що відбувається зараз,
і наступна пара – це теперішнє
ідеальне просте та минуле ідеальне просте,
а рука може бути трохи складною,
але все в порядку, тому
ми використовуємо це як попередню
дію, але  це має результат до
моменту промови, і дія, можливо, не
закінчилася насправді так, а ключові слова
вже просто ніколи ще ніколи ще відтоді
і для пам'ятаєш наш лайфхак
з долонею та пальцями, і ми
робили як ніколи просто  але оскільки
вже добре і past perfect simple
і використовується, коли ми дійшли до дій у
минулому, і ви хочете розповісти, що щось
відбулося раніше колись у минулому або
перед якоюсь дією в минулому, і
ключові слова є af  тер і раніше, тож
ось шанси, що ми збираємося переглянути
у вправах, тож перше
, будь ласка, візьміть свої олівці чи фунти
у свої зошити та запишіть їх
разом зі мною, добре, тому ми повинні
записати речення, які вам потрібно  використовуйте
правильну форму дієслів і для
заперечення та Q для запитання, щоб ви отримали
це речення, вони запрошують Лінду на
вечірку, і перше - теперішній час,
тому складіть свої речення, а потім давайте
перевіримо,
і ми перевіримо, щоб це було таким
чином  вони запрошують Лінду на вечірку вони
не запрошують або не запрошують Лінду на
вечірку вони запрошують Лінду на вечірку,
тому це теперішній час перевірте свої
відповіді, якщо у вас є якісь помилки,
виправте їх
добре наступне речення натисніть те саме
ситуація, але знову в минулому часі, у
вас є трохи часу, запишіть це
в минулому часі, чи готові ви перевірити,
чи запросили лідера на вечірку, яку вони
не запросили чи не запросили Лінду на
вечірку, чи запросили вони Лінду на вечірку  вечірка
I hop  e, ви зробили це правильно, добре, тому
наступна майбутня така ж ситуація і
майбутнє знову не поспішайте,
давайте перевіримо, щоб правильні відповіді:
вони запросять Лінду на вечірку,
вони не запросять або не запросять Лінду
на вечірку, чи запросять вони  Лінда на
вечірку добре, так що ви перевірили, і ми йдемо
далі наступна добре та сама ситуація,
але в теперішньому ідеальному злочині знайдіть деякий
час, запишіть це
і давайте перевіримо, щоб у теперішньому ідеальному це
має бути так, вони запросили
Лінду на вечірку, яку вони  не запросили
Лінду на вечірку чи запросили
Лінду на вечірку добре, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що
ви зробили все правильно, і тепер останнє завдання
на сьогодні - заповнити правильні
відповіді, тепер у вас є якісь
підказки з іншими нава  деякий час
виразів, тому ви повинні подумати про
час, який вам потрібен, і заповнити пропуски та
розкрити дужки насправді, щоб ми отримали
сюди, що Джон коли-небудь виграє приз на перегонах, якщо
Джон і Ава,
тому це ідеально, і має бути,
якщо Джон це  має бути Дж  о, коли-небудь
третій клас вигравав приз на перегонах, чи правильно я,
давайте перевіримо так, чи Джон коли-небудь вигравав
приз на перегонах, хлопці, ось як вам потрібно
виконати цю вправу я хочу, щоб
ви подумали, я хочу, щоб ви думали й розмовляли самі з собою
ви робите це, щоб зробити цей
логічний ланцюжок добре, ви готові до
другого речення, давайте подивимося, я заснув
вчора, коли я дивлюся телевізор, так це сталося
вчора, і одна дія була довгою,
і одна дія перервала іншу
, добре, подумайте 10  секунди
добре, давайте перевіримо під я заснув
вчора, коли я дивився телевізор
добре наступний Джордж ніколи не буде в Канаді
добре, ми говоримо про досвід Джорджа,
у нас є цей роман
і знову Джорджія, так це повинно бути
ніколи Райт ніколи не був  був у Канаді
чи має досвід, ми не кажемо, коли
сталася дія наступного разу Том
повернувся до Англії, він був у Італії на три
тижні, тому Том повернувся з відпустки,
подумайте трохи, добре, готовий побачити
відповідь, і він був  до Італії за
три тижні, і в результаті
він повернувся в Англію, добре наступний
номер п'ять, ми багато минулої неділі, я бачу,
втратили, і це має бути відразу після простого,
дуже легкого, тому ми зробили багато минулої
неділі,
добре, наступне, добре це  Одна
справді складна. Гаразд,
це серйозна ситуація насправді, тому зараз
невірний телефон Джилл знову це втретє, коли
він почув сьогодні ввечері, так що
може бути три різні шанси,
тому подумайте трохи, поговоріть із
собою, доведіть свою логіку та будьте готові
перевірити,
добре, я готовий перевірити про біг, давайте
подивимося,
зараз Рон телефонує Джилл знову, це
відбувається, зараз він
втретє знайшов її сьогодні ввечері, тому ми маємо
три різні часи, три різні
теперішні часи, добре, так що хлопці,
насправді, це  кінець уроку,
і я нагадую вам ваше домашнє завдання, тому ви
повинні оголосити про роботу, якщо вам потрібно
повернутися до уроку, переглянути всі
запитання та побачити зразок відповіді, зробити
майже таку ж копію з першого разу, а потім
ви зможете  робіть свої, тож
уважно дотримуйтесь рубрики та отримуйте задоволення від вивчення
англійської, мені було дуже приємно бути
з вами сьогодні,
мийте руки, будьте в безпеці, до побачення
[Музика]